you don't think the Ted Cruz felt that
way about CNN you don't think that that
George W Bush did you don't think that
Carly Fiorina did when she was smoking
Katie Couric and they were trying to say
that she was his failed CEO at HP but
she understands economics that they
don't of course they do but for some
reason they feel the need to sort of
cloak it through politeness Donald
Trump's no no wrong you're wrong
fake news you suck and I think that's
refreshing to people because a lot of
people have been streaming at the TV set
going why isn't someone can call them
out on them yeah you know the media
they're always telling us that Trump is
a liar but then you sort of contrast
that with the fact that many Americans I
don't know if it's most Americans but
certainly a significant portion they see
him as a straight shooter that's one of
the major selling points they seem as
more authentic than most politicians
what do you think it is I want to make
my case here so stay with me for a
little bit let me set this up so you
understand where I'm going yeah because
this is going to upset likely everybody
and I'm okay with it as long as you take
this and it's in its entirety the
context they need a little from column a
a little from column B okay I think he's
a little from column a and that he's
most definitely a bull yeah but a little
from column B in that I think he's much
more authentic than the sort of trained
empty suit politician yeah and I think
the column B matters more and the way
that you can tell at least is my opinion
that he's more genuine is for the same
reasons that a lot of people might hate
him you can identify the authenticity in
Trump through the things that he
disdains he can't hide the thing that he
hates he has no filter it seems no I
think that's an important litmus test
here people hate him because Allah he's
just tweeting all the time look at all
the things that he says well that's why
I don't think he would be able to hide
and play the game right let's also go to
something else like let's let's throw
into the mix a slurry okay yeah let me
give you this Donald Trump president
Donald Trump rally can definitely come
across scratch that he is an ass yeah
there's no doubt about that very
unlikable at times but I think everyone
kind of agrees it like okay at least
he's our ask both so people think like
at least he's because let's be honest
here what's the alternative at this
point yeah yeah Elizabeth Warren Pete
but gig data or orc and we think about
that the laser gun with the dreadlocks
that's getting Shane Gillis fired from
SNL yes and I want to be clear I'm not
not saying there's a good thing for
people to be in a hole yeah there are
plenty of people who aren't a-holes okay
that's the majority of America
unfortunately they don't run for
president most of the time but what's
the left when you have the Pete the Pete
but Giggsy Elizabeth Warren's even the
Bernie Sanders is is is it's it's a
slurry disguised as empathy yes right
that's that that's why I think people
seem as authentic you know Donald Trump
people might get mad at him because he
could say something to the equivalent of
this isn't a Redcoat but you know I
listen I think it is American dreamers
alive you should stop big lazy if you
want to text if you attach the rich more
go screw yourself okay they already pay
plenty that's that's pretty much it yeah
but then you have someone like Pete bud
king who says that you should get what
you know you should get what the times I
don't the exact quote in front of me I'm
free-flowing this a little bit you get
on terms if you're uncomfortable the
language it's being taken away from you
if you're uncomfortable to government
intruding into your life basically I'm
going to bully you into my point of view
and it's just a story just guys as
empathy yeah and I think that piss is a
lot of people off because we don't think
politicians have any genuine bones in
their body we know what they believe in
what they're saying and then they go out
into the media and they say something
that sounds much more pliable right like
it's much more easy to take and you're
like that's not what you believe I think
that's why so many people gravitate
towards Trump is because he's kind of
genuine oh he's a real ass right I can
see it and he's not trying to hide right
and people like we're all supposed to be
offended but everyone goes like I'm
talking about someone I'm pretty like
pissed off about like my neighbor my
neighbor who doesn't you know keep his
stuff on the other side of the fence I
probably feel this similarly to how
Trump feel about the New York Times yes
and so you can see yourself in that
person just like all great storytelling
it's about seeing yourself seeing the
facet of your character in somebody else
and um I think this is important also to
delineate what you just said to is
politicians they're trying to think
about what they believe
I don't think Trump necessarily knows
what he believes on every issue
you've seen him changing some issues
where he knows what he hates yeah he's
very very clear about that and I don't
mean he hates people I mean ideas I mean
establishments I mean institutions and I
think this sort of what seems is kind of
the Trump enigma because this is
something we talk about a lot of they
will go he's a compulsive liar he's a
bullshitter it was a I like the Trump's
it says it like it is and I think it's
important to explore that because it's
as though we're talking about the same
person with two different conversations
I don't think that's the case I don't
think we're too far off here I think
people hate him for the same reason that
people like him and that he is a book
artist okay so it's weird though to
people to say well he's also authentic
two different things let me explain to
you what we're talking about what
someone says for example he's a BS
artisan that he's self-serving Donald
Trump he can't bend the truth right -
maybe suit his own self-interest that's
different I think it's important that's
different from the essence of a human
being
yeah who they are and that's why Donald
Trump is kind of a bull but they see him
as a authentic because they don't see
him trying to disguise the things that
he believes as empathy so let's use bait
O'Rourke as an example okay yeah people
think he's compassionate paid over
people think that he's compassionate and
that he cares now what AM how when
miserable is talking about a mandatory
gun buyback yeah it's a confiscation
that is talking about okay let's be
really clear but banal or org disdains
freedom now I'm not attributing motive
when you're talking about someone who
wants to forcibly remove guns from the
American Republic that is someone who
disdains personal freedom who disdains a
Second Amendment but he cloaks it as
empathy and compassion Donald Trump
disdains the media and he cloaks it as
disdain for the media right in every
tweet thread that he's ever done pretty
much right there's a big difference so
actually I know we had this in a reverse
order but I would like to show for
people who haven't seen this debate Oh
or work click keep in mind before this
right and all how many times have you
heard the argument from the left so that
doesn't want to take your guns away
people are clinging to their Bibles and
religions that's not what they're
talking about they're talking about
reasonable gun reform beta or work
echoed those same sentiments now hear
him to thunderous applause say the
opposite of that hell yes we're gonna
take your ar-15 your ak-47
[Applause]
I'm listening to the people of this
country the day after I proposed doing
that I went to a gun show in Conway
Arkansas to meet with those who are
selling ar-15s an ak-47 originally I
willingly give that up cut it to pieces
I don't need this weapon to hunt to
defend myself it is a weapon of war so
let's do the right thing but let's bring
everyone in America into the
conversation Republicans Democrat
that's a great way to bring them in
let's bring everyone into the
conversation the gun owners we're gonna
take your gun let's bring everyone in
here come on we find some common ground
ok let's let's put Donald Trump in that
position Donald Trump obviously supports
the Second Amendment always and I think
he has a bit of a shaky record on guns
but can you Matt if Donald Trump
believes what bado
or work believes about firearms that he
just ain't somebody destines a second
moment he wants to have a mandatory
buyback paid or work for a long time was
saying we don't want to take your guns
we respect the Second Amendment we want
reasonable gun control but really he
believed in a mandatory buy that kind of
conversation Donald Trump if you were in
our position if he would say listen you
people are your people are crazy you
shouldn't have guns okay listen we're
gonna take him from you okay and I
frankly you should have them you Louie
Louie's you too okay it's because of the
NRA which is pathetic and their numbers
are dwindling and we're going to destroy
the NRA okay
the pathetic beauty that's what he would
say he wouldn't be able I don't think he
would be capable of lying and hoping
that same bait-and-switch if he truly
disdained firearms to the degree that
beta or worked us by the way hit the
notification bell for people who are out
there uh bookmark the page we have a new
video every single day 9 o'clock on
YouTube and 8 p.m. is the the live
stream now I want to compare that for
example beta O'Rourke can't stand
firearms he can't say that you own a
firearm that he described as a weapon of
war I'd be shocked if he knew the
difference between fully automatic and a
semi-automatic
compare that he compare that to the way
President Donald Trump talks about his
Second Amendment which is the New York
Times the papers going out of business
it's only a question of what
failing New York Times I probably won't
even be around in a few years based on
its financial outlook right okay so
under probably not that's a little bit
of biessing that's exaggerating right
but what he actually believes is
reflected there that the media is
corrupt that they hate him if they're
out to get him that it's a witch-hunt
there's no doubt about that no and and
they are not doing well financially
either right they're not doing that well
problems industry but he does exaggerate
that he does it that being said think
about this I think people need to sort
of reflect on themselves for a little
bit it's a lot harder to hide something
that you're upset about you know
something that sort of sticks in your
craw thorn in your side if you will if I
may it's a lot harder you meant to
disguise that than it is to say oh yeah
I I think that dress looks great it's
easier to do that yeah but it's
something that you really can't stand if
it's someone you read for exempt think
of something you really don't want it
Thanksgiving dinner so what do you know
whose abusive someone who is rude how
how easy is it for you to lie to that
person's face some people can not
everybody can and president Donald Trump
certainly is incapable unable I mean the
guy is incapable of filtering himself on
Twitter which by the way has multiple
checks and balances right yeah there's a
spellcheck doesn't care are you sure you
want to send this tweet there's I don't
think you ever actually reaches the
point that says do you want to save this
tweet or discard for later I don't see
this bride kill bait at fox boarding
Lisi oh okay now you're gonna talk bad
about me I hate fox said friend I think
it's I think he can be patty I think
it'd be very sensitive but I think there
is some authenticity to that and this is
why people again when you look at how
he's fought back against the media
listen they they were just as cruel with
Ted Cruz or Carly Fiorina or at one
point Marco Rubio or despite what they
try and say now george w bush which i
think we just saw with the whole with
the whole ellen debacle right yeah we're
saying well at least george w bush was a
decent man
donald trump is the worst there's no
comparison then ellen was caught my god
laughing with george w bush in a
football game and said hey i think we
should actually sit down with people you
disagree with and they said how
there you sit down with a war criminal
this person should be in jail george w
bush is evil they did the same thing
with everybody now you don't think for a
second that george w bush or ted cruz
take your pick
you don't think that they were they were
livid they were pissed beyond belief and
wanted to say hey new york times you're
full of crap you're a liar you're
dishonest you have a bias and I don't
think people need to necessarily listen
you I don't think people should take you
seriously you don't think that Ted Cruz
felt that way about CNN you don't think
that that George W Bush did you don't
think that Carly Fiorina did when she
was smoking Katie Couric and they were
trying to say that she was his failed
CEO at HP but she understands economics
that they don't of course they do but
for some reason they feel the need to
sort of cloak it through politeness
right they need to cloak it in this this
veil of politeness like well I
understand why you're asking that
question but I disagree Donald Trump's
no no wrong you're wrong dude you suck
and I think that's refreshing to people
because a lot of people in streaming at
the TV said go why isn't someone to call
him out on this yes and here's something
else it's not only these authentic about
the things that he disdains this is I
don't think again Donald Trump knows
exactly what he believes but he does
know what he hates and this is another I
think picture perfect example or a
counter argument rather to people who
accuse him of being a racist yeah
listen Donald Trump wants to build the
wall yeah okay he wants Mexico to pay
for the wall he wanted to put like
spikes on the wall which is hysterical
yes in the moat
Donald Trump did you see when he just
tweeted the democratic debate sit down
at his Twitter and and talk with some
consultants and clear it with three
levels yeah I believe lacks intellectual
diversity yes you know he's not a racist
because he he wants the wall could it
build a wall it's gonna be you know what
Mexico's gonna pay for it he hates ms-13
because they're a edibles these people
right
he can't stand ANSI Pelosi thinks AOC is
crazy he's open about all of those
things but let's just take the walls an
example build a wall let's enhance our
cybersecurity
let's keep people out of this country
let's boot people who are here illegally
why
oh why would he be oh so careful to stop
it saying and it's because they're
filthy Mexicans yeah that way that's
what he would say I would absolutely say
it yes that would be his equivalent to a
gun confiscation same people say he's a
racist all of his pot well first off you
have to look at prison reform you have
to look at what Donald Trump is actually
done for black people yeah look at his
actions he is show me any proof that
Donald Trump has personally acted out of
a racist malice you won't be able to
find it and I know some people will find
some some people in his organizations
who said that there was something no
you'll never find from Donald Trump you
gave our City Hall the award for
Celebrity Apprentice and you really
didn't deserve it if Donald Trump
disdained something he does he is not we
have at least I should say this we have
not seen in ability from him any
capacity whatsoever to fake it he can
vote the details he can exaggerate in a
way that self-serving but he cannot hide
the truth and in this case I guess it
would be appropriate he cannot hide his
truth the whole time I've ever even done
if someone said the Donald Trump people
yes I like that I like that your truth
by truth is boring you suck my truth is
okay you're that there's no more
subscriptions to newspaper that's my
truth he is so petty
and so and I don't think it's
necessarily ill-founded yeah I think it
would be petty if they were being
attacked yeah use a couple more examples
here like george w bush okay and yeah
the war on terror in the iraq war right
right if people if everyone came and
obviously Donald Trump was against the
war in Iraq which looking back he
probably was right about that in a sense
he was certainly right in the sense that
it's not something you can win it
becomes a quagmire he's we can't install
democracy around the world okay I agree
with him on that that being said if it
were george w bush and people were just
beating him mercilessly about the Iraq
war Donald Trump wouldn't have sat there
and and just talked about freedom and
talking about how much we said oh listen
okay I'm so sorry I'm so sorry that
you're all against me frankly the war in
Iraq when 84% of you supported
okay I forgot I forgot that all of you
supported it until all of a sudden you
didn't okay I'm sorry I'm sorry frankly
that 911 happened on my watch
Oh way no I'm not because I didn't do it
and you're lying and you're boring and
you suck yeah that's how we do it
exactly how you respond it would be like
that's right they were all for the war
before they said they were against it
right be like that finally somebody safe
he were Barack Obama let's go rock obama
when you have next scenario then you
have the housing crisis right the red
button obviously start under george w
bush but then it really kinda canis
crescendo under obama and larger Fannie
Mae Freddie Mac you've been okay oh
listen it's terrible what happened with
the housing market okay so I understand
frankly that you're upset about it oh
wait no I don't because you are the ones
who all wanted to have affordable
housing and home loans with nobody dead
and horrible credit oh I'm so sorry that
you can't manage your own body I think
you just go through any example of a
president historically and go through
what they disdained yeah let's go to
Abraham Lincoln if Abraham Lincoln were
Donald Trump he was talking about the
slaves yeah let's even go to like the
Emancipation Proclamation pick anything
he would go okay listen I understand
that you guys what slavery oh no wait
your are about your eggs okay how bad I
believe frankly are created equal
and you believe not that so if you were
Paul Revere but dig dig dig dig the
psychic excerpt coming I think I know I
read the British British but I call it
the facts because that's what I think of
them frankly they're coming they're
coming and we're gonna kick their ass
cuz their ball rig I think that there is
something refreshing about that but I
don't think that the two are mutually
exclusive painting
we're subscribe to the channel hit the
notification bell if you're already
subscribed to this channel because that
lets you know when new videos come out
and they don't show up on the youtube
search feed also there are videos
playing in boxes here click one of those
just of all the things that I just
mentioned
all you have to do is one and if you
don't I will run for the United States
presidency under the one one thousand
sixty four percent Cherokee party I have
yet to pick my VP